Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一个激动人心的消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我和我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）共同举办的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是准心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Do you really know what OCD is? Spoiler alert, it is not just about being neat and tidy.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由丽莎本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的 Linktree 页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的话题吧。你真的了解强迫症（OCD）吗？剧透一下，它不仅仅是关于整洁和有序。
In this episode, we uncover the truth about OCD, the distress it causes and the treatments that can help. If you or someone you care about struggles with intrusive thoughts and compulsive behaviours, this is one you're not going to want to miss. Hi, welcome along. I am Dr. Marianne and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Now, OCD does get spoken about by lots and lots of people, but often in quite a throwaway manner. This is not that. You know, I spend a great deal of my time as a clinical psychologist and providing therapy for people who are really, you know, have their lives very much affected by the far-reaching implications of OCD. So this episode is all about what it is, how it can take hold. And, you know, we're trying to normalize and validate people's experiences so that they are more able to grapple with this and to be able to take control. If you find this helpful, wherever you are watching or listening,
在这一集中，我们将揭开强迫症的真相，探讨它带来的痛苦以及可以提供帮助的治疗方法。如果你或你关心的人正在与侵入性思维和强迫行为作斗争，那么这一集你绝对不能错过。嗨，欢迎收听。我是玛丽安博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。现在，很多人都在谈论强迫症，但往往是以一种非常随意的方式。今天我们要谈的不是那种。作为一名临床心理学家，我花费大量时间为那些生活深受强迫症深远影响的人提供治疗。所以这一集的主题是：它是什么，它是如何控制人的。我们试图让人们的经历正常化并得到认可，这样他们就能更好地应对并掌控自己的生活。如果你觉得这有帮助，无论你在哪里观看或收听，
please do like, subscribe, drop some comments and give this video some love. I will look forward to catching up with you on the other side and I hope you find it really, really useful. Hi, I just want to welcome along our guest for today, Faye. Hi, welcome along to the podcast. Hi, thanks Marianne. Thank you for having me. Thank you for having me. Thank you for pitching your idea for the episode to us. Before we crack on with our content,
请点赞、订阅、留下评论并支持这个视频。我期待在节目后与大家交流，希望你们觉得这非常有价值。嗨，我想欢迎我们今天的嘉宾费伊（Faye）。嗨，欢迎来到播客。嗨，谢谢玛丽安。谢谢你邀请我。谢谢你向我们提出这个节目的构思。在我们开始内容之前，
thinking about OCD and striving for careers, could you tell the audience and myself a little bit about you, please, Faye? Yeah, so my name's Faye. I am a psychological wellbeing practitioner, or PWP for short, very recently qualified. So just to give a brief overview, I work with people with common mental health difficulties, depression, anxiety, OCD, you know, those sorts of things. Yeah, and that's what I do as a full-time job. I've worked in mental health for a few years now in various different roles before I got into doing the PWP work. And I am someone who also lives with OCD. So that's a very important part of, you know, my role and me as a person as well. Thank you so much.
考虑到强迫症和职业追求，费伊，你能向观众和我介绍一下你自己吗？好的，我叫费伊。我是一名心理健康从业者（PWP），刚获得资格不久。简单介绍一下，我的工作是帮助那些有常见心理健康问题的人，比如抑郁、焦虑、强迫症等等。这就是我的全职工作。在从事 PWP 工作之前，我在心理健康领域工作了几年，担任过各种不同的角色。我也是一名强迫症患者。所以，这也是我个人以及我职业角色中非常重要的一部分。非常感谢。
If people did want to hear more about what PWPs are and, you know, how they can train as one and what the reality of working as a PWP is like they can listen to the episode I recorded that was out very recently actually with Ben Olofsson but let's hear a little bit more about you and OCD so when did that first become apparent maybe not to yourself maybe to other people when was that first in your life? So it's interesting I think with OCD obviously what we often think of it is it can be really apparent to the people around you but my OCD tended to manifest in more sort of mental compulsions rather than physical so it wasn't always obvious to the people who were around me. I think probably you know looking, it started maybe when I was around 17, 18 years old, but I didn't get sort of diagnosed until later on, until I was,
如果大家想更多地了解什么是 PWP，如何接受培训，以及作为 PWP 的真实工作状态，可以去听我最近录制的一期节目，嘉宾是本·奥洛夫森（Ben Olofsson）。但让我们多聊聊你和强迫症，它是何时开始显现的？也许不是对你自己，而是对其他人，它在你的生活中是什么时候出现的？这很有趣，我认为对于强迫症，人们通常认为它对周围的人来说非常明显，但我的强迫症更多表现为心理强迫，而不是身体强迫，所以对我周围的人来说并不总是那么明显。我想大概是在我 17、18 岁的时候开始的，但我直到后来，也就是大约
you know, around 21, 22. So it was a bit of a journey to kind of, you know, come to terms with that, you know, what was going on. I didn't know a lot about OCD at the time that I started experiencing it so for me it was very difficult to kind of have that inward battle and feel like you're the only person in the world who's experiencing this just not knowing what was going on was really scary so when I sort of started to think that maybe this might be OCD I remember sort of googling a lot of my symptoms at the time and it would come up with all these different OCD forums and I thought well that can't be me because I don't you know excessively wash my hands, I'm not like very particular about where I put things. So I brushed it off for a really long time and you know the more I sort
21、22 岁时才被诊断出来。所以，接受这一切并弄清楚发生了什么，是一个漫长的过程。当时我对强迫症了解不多，所以对我来说，进行那种内心的斗争非常困难，感觉自己是世界上唯一经历这些的人，不知道发生了什么真的很可怕。所以当我开始认为这可能是强迫症时，我记得当时在谷歌上搜索了很多症状，结果跳出来各种强迫症论坛，我想“那肯定不是我，因为我不过度洗手，也不对物品的摆放位置非常挑剔”。所以我很长一段时间都忽略了它，你知道，随着我
of got into that googling spiral you know as as people with OCD often tend to do, it was becoming a bit more apparent to me that actually, you know, maybe OCD is something a bit more than just sort of, you know, cleanliness and orderliness. So, yeah, that's when I kind of started to notice. Yeah, you make such a brilliant point there that it's not just about, you know, switching on and off light switches or, you know, getting the gas dials on your hob just right. You know, what OCD is and how I explain it to clients that I work with. I should also say that you and I have never worked together therapeutically. This is a professional chat. So I hope that this feels OK, but please let me know if it doesn't and we can cut any bits out that that don't work for you as I explain OCD to to everybody really whether it's my clients or just
陷入那种谷歌搜索的漩涡（强迫症患者常有的行为），我开始意识到，实际上强迫症不仅仅是关于清洁和整洁。所以，是的，那时我开始注意到了。你说得太对了，它不仅仅是关于开关灯，或者确保炉灶上的旋钮位置正确。关于什么是强迫症，以及我如何向我的客户解释它——我也应该说明，你和我从未在治疗层面合作过，这是一次专业的聊天。如果这让你感到不适，请告诉我，我们可以剪掉不合适的部分。当我向大家解释强迫症时，无论是对我的客户还是
people I chat with OCD is you know an impulsive and intrusive thought that all of us might have it might be a really logical thought about something that becomes distressing and it's then the activity that you take to kind of neutralize and to bring that distress down with a belief that that will somehow help that to not happen or that it will make the likelihood of something else happen so for example somebody has a thought that oh it's it's cold out there. It's dark. And then they think, you know, it's a sense they make of that. Oh, you know, my loved one is actually still out at the moment. Then they begin to make, you know, their attributions to that. You know, I'm worried that something might happen to them because it is so cold and so dark. Gosh, that would be awful. That would be horrendous. Or maybe I'll, you know, I'll have to sit and do this all, you know, 15 times until it feels right. And I'm sorry for anyone listening to that on MP3. I was clicking a pen there, if you're not watching it on YouTube. I was clicking, you know, a multi-colour pen, but
与我聊天的人，强迫症是一种冲动和侵入性的想法，我们所有人可能都会有。它可能是一个关于某事的非常合乎逻辑的想法，但变得令人痛苦，然后你采取行动来中和它，以减轻这种痛苦，并相信这会以某种方式阻止事情发生，或者增加某事发生的可能性。例如，有人想到“外面很冷，天很黑”。然后他们会赋予这个想法意义：“我爱的人现在还在外面。”然后他们开始进行归因：“我担心因为天气太冷太黑，他们可能会出事。天哪，那太可怕了，太糟糕了。”或者“也许我必须坐在这里做这件事 15 次，直到感觉对了。”对于正在听 MP3 的人，我很抱歉，如果你们没在看 YouTube，我刚才在按一支笔。我是在按一支多色笔，但是
it's that sense of until it feels right or until it feels manageable and that might be different on different days and what we know is that that can change so what initially kind of placates that and brings the distress down doesn't always work or the one strategy stops working over time and then you kind of have to ramp it up and that's when it really begins to impact on your well-being and sometimes your functioning and your ability to to look after yourself and and strive for normal basic functions let alone a career does that encapsulate your experience of OCD? You understand they feel different? Yeah, no, I completely agree with what you've said there.
那种“直到感觉对了”或“直到感觉可以应付”的感觉，在不同的日子里可能会有所不同。我们知道这种情况会改变，所以最初能缓解痛苦的方法并不总是有效，或者某种策略随着时间的推移失效了，你不得不加大力度，这就是它真正开始影响你的幸福感、功能，以及你照顾自己和追求基本生活功能（更不用说职业）的能力的时候。这概括了你的强迫症经历吗？你明白它们感觉不同吗？是的，我完全同意你所说的。
And, you know, the main thing is, and I think as explained quite nicely there, it's the compulsion that is the part that can really begin to take over your life. You know, it's not the the thoughts themselves although they are really distressing the compulsions are really what sort of has a big impact on sort of well-being functioning if you are you have a compulsion that you need to do over and over and over again and you can't you know move on to something until that compulsion feels right or it feels that you've done it enough times or you know that anxiety has eventually lowered it impacts on everything you know it impacts on your ability to work it can impact on your ability to you know there were
最主要的是，正如刚才解释的那样，强迫行为是真正开始接管你生活的部分。并不是想法本身，尽管它们确实非常令人痛苦，但强迫行为才是对幸福感和功能产生巨大影响的原因。如果你有一种需要一遍又一遍重复的强迫行为，并且在感觉“对了”或者你觉得已经做了足够多次，或者焦虑最终降低之前，你无法继续做其他事情，这会影响一切。它影响你的工作能力，它会影响你的能力……有
times and and you know lengthy periods of time where I struggled to get out of bed because I was going through these mental compulsions in my head and it took me so long that by the time the anxiety had lowered you know it could have been minutes hours later and the thing is that you know that anxiety does eventually lower but oftentimes what happens then is you know you've done that compulsion you feel better and a few minutes later there's a new intrusive thought and you have to go through the whole process again so it can be extremely time consuming and I think that is when sometimes it can start to become apparent to the other people around you as well that something's not quite right yeah distress is the word that probably isn't always spoken about enough with OCD this is
一段时间，甚至是很长一段时间，我挣扎着无法起床，因为我脑子里在进行这些心理强迫行为。这花费了我太长时间，以至于当焦虑降低时，可能已经是几小时后了。问题是，焦虑确实最终会降低，但通常发生的情况是，你完成了强迫行为，感觉好了一些，几分钟后又出现了一个新的侵入性想法，你必须重新经历整个过程。所以这非常耗时，我认为这就是为什么有时它开始对周围的人变得明显，因为有些事情不太对劲。是的，痛苦这个词在强迫症中谈论得还不够多，这
deeply distressing and you know it's not a case of as often people will try and help you. Come on, just stop it. Just stop it. It's not that easy. This is deeply distressing. And, you know, often it will crop up. You know, I heard you say that it was around 17. And I know that's a really key time for for mocks, for AS levels, for A levels, perhaps for kind of college stuff but also you know people's health might falter a parent's health might falter and then it puts that stresses those cracks on or maybe the anxiety of having to kind of be independent get around to college there can be so many things at whatever time of life it is that kind of yeah leave that vulnerability for OCD to be able to get in and
是非常痛苦的。这不像人们常试图帮助你的那样：“来吧，停下来，停下来。”没那么简单。这是非常痛苦的。而且，它经常会突然出现。我听到你说是在 17 岁左右，我知道那是模拟考试、AS 水平考试、A 水平考试的关键时期，也许还有大学相关的事情，但人们的健康也可能受损，父母的健康也可能受损，这会增加压力，或者因为必须独立、去上大学而产生的焦虑，在人生的任何阶段都有很多事情会留下让强迫症趁虚而入的脆弱点，
even when in recovery and in remission or in between chunks of OCD it's really important to kind of look after well-being and self-care to to try and safeguard from finding its way in again as a strategy because it it's like you, if we're thinking of externalizing it, it's like it almost whispers to you, you know, this is going to make it better. This is going to make you feel better. This is going to help. And it kind of seduces you.
即使在康复期、缓解期或强迫症发作的间隙，关注幸福感和自我保健也非常重要，以防止它再次作为一种策略潜入。因为它就像……如果我们把它外化来看，它几乎是在向你低语：“这会让事情变好。这会让你感觉更好。这会有帮助。”它有点像在诱惑你。
And before you know it, it's your best friend again and it's telling you lots of stuff. But it's just really hard, you know. And I realized when I was recording an episode, actually when I was doing some clinical work with a client, it wasn't a podcast, that I had been doing something for 20 years or something like that for 20 years. Since my finals at uni, I'd been folding the clothes I sleep in
在你意识到之前，它又成了你最好的朋友，告诉你很多事情。但这真的很难。我意识到，当我在录制一期节目时，实际上是在和一位客户进行临床工作时，那不是播客，我意识到我已经做了某件事 20 年了，或者类似 20 年。自从我大学期末考试以来，我一直把睡觉时穿的衣服叠好，
and putting them under my pillow just right so that I wouldn't, I would do okay in my finals. And then it was only when I was with them and we were talking about the kind of normal stuff that we do that I realized I'm still doing that, you know, and I've never had an OCD diagnosis, but this is, you know, this can be, this can crop up in normal life. Clearly wasn't affecting my functioning, but it's so easy for things to happen. Even kind of superstition, beliefs about superstition, not passing on the stairs, you know, that is rooted in OCD, you know, and it's, yeah, it's, it's, it's, you know, omnipresent. Could you tell us a little bit about mental compulsions, please? Maybe not your own if that feels too intrusive or personal, but just as you've picked up along the time. Yeah, absolutely. So mental compulsions covers, you know, a whole range of behaviours. And I think
放在枕头下，摆放得恰到好处，这样我在期末考试中就能表现得好。直到我和他们在一起，谈论我们做的那些正常事情时，我才意识到我还在这样做。我从未被诊断出强迫症，但这确实会出现在正常生活中。显然它没有影响我的功能，但事情很容易发生。甚至迷信，关于迷信的信念，不在楼梯上经过，这都植根于强迫症。它无处不在。你能给我们讲讲心理强迫吗？也许不是你自己的，如果这让你觉得太侵入或太私人的话，只是你随着时间推移所了解到的。好的，当然。心理强迫涵盖了一系列行为。我认为
the important thing to know about compulsions is they can be very different and they vary from person to person I know a big one for me was kind of this feeling of having to sort of tell people you know sort of confession so I had a period where I was very focused on sort of being kind of morally correct and everything being perfect and never telling any kind of lies or anything like that so it could be something as you know inconsequential as I told someone oh this person was wearing a pink shirt and then a few minutes later I realized oh actually that person was actually wearing a blue shirt and that would take up you know that would cause me so much distress to the fact that I had not completely told the truth that I would have to go back and correct myself and say to this person actually I was wrong I didn't tell the truth that person was actually wearing a blue shirt not pink
关于强迫行为，重要的一点是它们非常不同，因人而异。我知道对我来说，一个很大的强迫行为是那种必须告诉人们的感觉，也就是“忏悔”。我有一段时间非常专注于道德上的正确，一切都要完美，从不说任何谎言。所以这可能是不重要的事，比如我告诉某人“那个人穿着粉色衬衫”，几分钟后我意识到“哦，实际上那个人穿的是蓝色衬衫”。这会让我感到非常痛苦，因为我没有完全说实话，以至于我不得不回去纠正自己，对那个人说：“实际上我错了，我没说实话，那个人穿的是蓝色衬衫，不是粉色
shirt and that would be what I would have to do to kind of you know I suppose bring that anxiety down and make me feel better so you know that is a huge part of it also you know maybe asking for reassurance around things counting sort of inside your head is a huge mental compulsion for a lot of people sort of going over things mentally reviewing and you know there's a huge subset I suppose of OCD around maybe false memories so kind of thinking having an intrusive thought and believing that thought has actually happened in the past or you know you've done something wrong or you've done something bad and having to mentally sort of go back to that you know moment in time and review it and think you know
衬衫。”这就是我必须做的，为了缓解焦虑，让自己感觉好受些。所以，这是很大的一部分。此外，也许寻求关于某事的保证，在脑子里计数，对很多人来说是一种巨大的心理强迫。在脑子里反复回顾事情，有一个关于“虚假记忆”的强迫症子集，即产生一个侵入性想法，并相信这个想法在过去真的发生过，或者你做错了什么，或者你做了坏事，不得不回到那个时刻去回顾它，思考：
what have I done here did I do everything correctly have I done something wrong and just going over that events over and over again so there's a lot of different mental compulsions and they're not always visible to others or very apparent to others. That is a lot, isn't it? And I imagine it's quite hard to go to sleep as you're ruminating and processing over all of that. So it must really impact on every aspect of your life, your physical health, your mental health your ability to to do anything how do you strive for a career when you've got that level of kind of anguish going
“我做了什么？我做得对吗？我做错什么了吗？”然后一遍又一遍地回顾这些事件。所以有很多不同的心理强迫，它们对他人来说并不总是可见或明显的。这确实很多，不是吗？我想当你反刍和处理所有这些事情时，入睡一定很困难。所以它一定真的影响了你生活的方方面面，你的身体健康、心理健康、做任何事情的能力。当你每分钟都在经历那种痛苦时，你是如何追求职业生涯的？
on on a minute by minute basis sometimes it's a load of question really and I think part of me I've always wanted to work in mental health but this was something that I was very passionate about and I cared a lot about so I think that always helps at the time you know at my worst periods when it when you know when I'm talking about these compulsions that I was doing this was you know the a few months long where it went on for for quite some time and it was impacting my functioning but at that time I was actually finishing off my undergraduate degree. We were in sort of that period of Covid, the initial Covid period where it was locked down and you know you couldn't go outside and see people so everything
这是一个很难的问题。我想我一直想在心理健康领域工作，这是我非常热衷且关心的事情，所以我认为这总是有帮助的。在最糟糕的时期，当我谈论这些强迫行为时，那持续了几个月，影响了我的功能，但当时我实际上正在完成我的本科学位。我们处于新冠疫情期间，最初的封锁期，你不能出门见人，所以一切
had moved online. It was incredibly incredibly difficult, I won't sugarcoat it, I was doing my you know final year exams for university getting around to do my dissertation I would find myself incredibly pressed for time a lot of the time you know I wasn't studying and actually there was a period of time where I did fail a lot of my exams because I could not get out of bed I could not get to the point of, you know, studying or even going to my lectures. I missed a lot of lectures because of this. And I eventually actually, you know, reset one of the exams that I failed. And because I failed it a second time, I was dismissed from the university. But this was sort of after my second year. So, you know, kind of getting kicked out essentially from uni
都转到了线上。这非常非常困难，我不会粉饰它。我当时正在进行大学期末考试，还要准备论文。我发现自己经常时间非常紧迫，我没有学习。实际上有一段时间我挂了很多科，因为我无法起床，无法达到学习甚至去上课的程度。因为这个，我错过了很多课。最终我重修了其中一门挂掉的考试。因为第二次又挂了，我被大学开除了。这是在我大二之后。所以，基本上因为
because of the, you know, the level of distress that I had and the fact that I couldn't really function very well. And at that time, I didn't know what was going on. I did not know that this was OCD. So it was incredibly difficult and it's not easy to kind of strive for that at times. And there were times that I felt like kind of just given up and, you know, thrown in the towel and saying,
我所承受的痛苦程度以及我无法很好地发挥功能，我被大学开除了。当时我不知道发生了什么。我不知道这是强迫症。所以这非常困难，有时很难去追求那些目标。有几次我感觉想放弃，想认输，说：
maybe this isn't for me, you know. There were times that I thought that maybe I was just lazy or, you know, I couldn't, I wasn't as smart as other people. Why was I failing everything? You know, why couldn't I just, you know, get up and do these things? But it was because these compulsions and this distress was taking up so much time and so much energy that I did not have the energy for for anything else yeah gosh
“也许这不适合我。”有几次我以为自己只是懒，或者我不像其他人那么聪明。为什么我什么都做不好？为什么我不能起床做这些事？但这是因为这些强迫行为和痛苦占据了太多的时间和精力，以至于我没有精力做其他任何事情。是的，天哪。
I'm so sorry to hear about that and you know OCD takes so much from the people that it affects you know but actually that's also a real financial impact as well that that's two years of funding that you have presumably have to repay and and then to get yourself to where you are you need to ultimately do another degree perhaps all three years again like and you know I was as you're talking thinking about my experiences in this weekend I'm actually going to go and see my undergraduate friends. We're going to go and have a lunch and shopping date together. But it would have been, I don't know, like you lost out on those relationships with people. I hope you might still be in touch with them, but you lost the chance to be carefree and to do what everyone else who was your age was likely doing at that time because you were so distressed and so consumed by this that's a really big deal yeah absolutely you know I do think back on those
听到这些我很难过。强迫症从受影响的人身上夺走了太多东西。但实际上，这也有真正的经济影响，那是两年的学费，你可能不得不偿还。然后为了达到你现在的水平，你最终可能需要再读一个学位，或者把三年重新读一遍。当你说话时，我想到我这个周末的经历，我正要去见我的大学朋友。我们要一起吃午餐、逛街。但如果是你，你失去了与人的那些关系。我希望你还能和他们保持联系，但你失去了无忧无虑的机会，失去了做那个年纪其他人可能正在做的事情的机会，因为你太痛苦了，被这些东西消耗了。这真的很严重。是的，绝对。我确实会回想那些
times and it is unfortunate that you know the time that I spent inside at home you know just not being able to get out of bed because I was all consumed by OCD and I think the biggest part of it for me was the not knowing not knowing what was wrong with me feeling like I was the only person in the world that was dealing with this and you know there was something really really wrong with me because I couldn't do the the things that other people were doing and you're right I really kind of struggled with you know making relationships with other people because I couldn't spend that time I was never fully present in moments where I maybe would have liked to been so it did have a huge impact on just sort of my university life and then obviously kind of going
时光，很不幸，我待在家里，因为被强迫症完全消耗而无法起床。对我来说，最大的一部分是“不知道”。不知道自己出了什么问题，感觉自己是世界上唯一一个处理这些问题的人，感觉自己真的出了什么大问题，因为我无法做其他人正在做的事情。你是对的，我确实在与人建立关系方面挣扎，因为我无法花时间，我从未完全活在当下，在那些我可能想活在当下的时刻。所以这对我的大学生活产生了巨大的影响，然后显然
back to university you know through Covid that added another layer onto it where you couldn't you know you couldn't go out and meet new people so it did have a huge impact on you know that that period of my life. It sounds like there was some missed opportunities along the way actually Faye perhaps after your A levels or whatever secondary education you were doing and perhaps student support should have really brought you in to think about what was going on because of the high number of missed lectures and just where you were hitting the mark academically compared to what your potential was perhaps and do you have a sense of what might have made a difference yeah no I think you're
通过新冠疫情回到大学，这又增加了一层困难，你无法出去结识新朋友。所以这对我的那段人生确实产生了巨大的影响。听起来一路上有一些错失的机会，费伊。也许在你的 A 水平考试或你正在接受的任何中学教育之后，学生支持部门本应该真正介入，思考发生了什么，因为缺课率很高，而且你的学术表现与你的潜力相比。你觉得什么可能会有所不同？是的，我想你是
right and I think you know you don't want to kind of dwell too much on it and you know in the past because you know these things have happened now and I often look back on it and think that was the best thing that actually could have happened for me in that time because this is where I am now but I think you're 100% correct and you know mental health support you know I think quite famously throughout secondary schools and you know moving up into higher education isn't always the best so you know a bit of support probably would have you know gone a long way I think in in that instance I think also as well just acknowledging the fact that it wasn't so obvious to even to myself that you know particularly what was wrong or to other people so people may have asked and I may have just said you know I'm fine and everything's okay because I
对的。你不想过多地沉溺于过去，因为这些事情已经发生了。我经常回首往事，认为那是我当时能发生的最棒的事情，因为才有了现在的我。但我认为你是 100% 正确的。心理健康支持，我认为在中学和高等教育中并不总是最好的。所以，一点支持可能会在那种情况下大有帮助。我也认为，承认即使对我自己来说，也不清楚到底出了什么问题，或者对其他人来说也不清楚，这一点也很重要。所以人们可能问过，我可能只是说“我很好，一切都好”，因为我
wasn't really sure what was going on so it's interesting that you bring that up but this is why it's so important to cultivate that awareness around OCD and bring it more into you know just the public lexicon and you know just get that understanding because what people think OCD is is a very very limited what what it really is and you know everything that OCD encompasses and it's still used you know to this day quite you know in in quite a flippant way where people like you know I'm a little bit OCD or because they you know they like to clean and that has a huge impact on the people who are actually struggling with OCD because they don't get the chance to learn what this is and they might be going through the same struggles that I did where they they're having these thoughts they're having these compulsions
真的不确定发生了什么。所以你提出这一点很有趣。这就是为什么培养对强迫症的认识，并将其更多地纳入公共词汇中如此重要。我们需要获得这种理解，因为人们认为强迫症是什么，是非常非常有限的。它实际上是什么，以及强迫症包含的一切。直到今天，它仍然被相当轻率地使用，人们会说“我有点强迫症”，因为他们喜欢打扫卫生。这对那些真正与强迫症作斗争的人产生了巨大的影响，因为他们没有机会了解这是什么。他们可能正在经历和我一样的挣扎，他们有这些想法，有这些强迫行为，
but because they're not in line with what they know about OCD they they internalize it and they keep it to themselves and they they don't seek out diagnosis knowledge that actually it can take years and years and years I think it's something between you know up to 14 years it can take someone to to get an OCD diagnosis and I think a huge part of that is to do with the fact that it's so misunderstood and it could just having that knowledge and raising that awareness could go a really long way in in supporting people. on people absolutely um you know the pathologization of of OCD being so common in people is something I've spoken about in on my socials but it's not you know OCD needs to impact on function risk you know well-being you know needs many, many problems. But if actually you really just like a very clean house, but you're able to do all of your things without denting your well-being,
但因为它们与他们所了解的强迫症不符，他们将其内化，保持沉默，不去寻求诊断。了解这一点实际上可能需要几年、几年、几年。我认为这需要长达 14 年的时间才能让某人获得强迫症诊断。我认为这很大程度上是因为它被严重误解了。仅仅拥有这些知识并提高认识，就能在支持人们方面大有作为。绝对。你知道，强迫症在人们中被病理化是非常普遍的，我在我的社交媒体上谈论过这一点。但强迫症需要影响功能、风险、幸福感，需要很多很多问题。但如果你真的只是喜欢一个非常干净的房子，但你能够完成所有事情而不损害你的幸福感，
you know, that is not OCD. That might be some reliefs around cleanliness, you know, and you know, what dirt is might be a fear about what other people would say about you but if if you are able to be entirely functional get everything done your well-being is radiant your house smells like you know stacy solomon wax melts or whatever like uh you know and you're not a risk to yourself or others you don't always have to have risk to yourself or others for OCD, but it can become that because it's so distressing that sometimes people don't want to live anymore because it's so, we can't dial back time for you. But, you know, people listening to this podcast, perhaps working in student services, can become more aware. Perhaps working in higher education, like, oh, this could be a possibility. How could I gently explore this? You know, and, you know, red, raw or bleeding hands is a really easy way in or it can help join up the dots. But without that,
那不是强迫症。那可能是一些关于清洁的缓解，或者对污垢的恐惧，或者对别人会怎么评价你的恐惧。但如果你能够完全发挥功能，完成所有事情，你的幸福感是灿烂的，你的房子闻起来像 Stacy Solomon 的蜡烛味，或者无论什么，而且你对自己或他人没有风险——你并不总是需要对自己或他人有风险才算强迫症，但它可能会变成那样，因为它太痛苦了，有时人们不想再活下去了。我们无法为你拨回时间。但是，听这个播客的人，也许在学生服务部门工作，可以变得更加了解。也许在高等教育部门工作，会想“这可能是一种可能性”。我该如何温和地探索这一点？你知道，手部红肿或流血是一个非常简单的切入点，或者它可以帮助把点连起来。但如果没有这些，
it can be really, really difficult to kind of help work out what's going on. But also, you need to feel like you trust the person you're speaking to and that it feels safe to have that conversation. But it sounds very much like you were really trying to just keep yourself to yourself to get through each day. Yeah, absolutely. And another thing about OCD and what's not spoken about so much is those intrusive thoughts that might be actually a bit more taboo, you know, thoughts around safety. People might have thoughts ofoo you know thoughts around safety people might have thought of you know a really common one is that fear of losing control so people might have a big fear around sort of knives because they think you know if I'm near that I might lose control and I might you know I might
要弄清楚发生了什么可能会非常非常困难。而且，你需要觉得你信任你正在交谈的人，并且觉得进行那种对话是安全的。但听起来你当时确实是在努力保持自我，以度过每一天。是的，绝对。关于强迫症，还有一件事谈论得不多，那就是那些可能更禁忌的侵入性想法。你知道，关于安全的想法。人们可能会有……你知道，关于安全的想法。一个非常常见的想法是害怕失去控制。所以人们可能对刀具非常恐惧，因为他们认为“如果我靠近那个，我可能会失去控制，我可能会伤害自己，我可能会伤害别人”。
harm myself I may harm someone else and to to have those kind of thoughts and to not know why you're having them and to not know that that is a really common symptom of OCD is incredibly incredibly distressing and no wonder like as you said people do get to the point of you know wanting to take their own lives because they think something is seriously wrong with them and they're they're a risk to themselves or to others when actually you know it it's not congruent with with how you actually feel with your values it's very much you know OCD latches on to the things that you really care about so if you really value you know your family it may be that you then have intrusive thoughts of something bad happening to them or causing them harm and that is why those thoughts become so overstressed then because you you care about that
拥有这些想法，却不知道为什么会有这些想法，也不知道这是强迫症的一个非常常见的症状，是非常非常痛苦的。难怪正如你所说，人们会达到想要结束自己生命的地步，因为他们认为自己出了严重的问题，对自己或他人构成风险。而实际上，这与你的真实感受、你的价值观并不一致。强迫症非常倾向于抓住你真正关心的事情。所以如果你非常重视你的家人，你可能会有关于他们发生坏事或伤害他们的侵入性想法。这就是为什么那些想法变得如此令人痛苦，因为你在乎，
and you don't want that to happen you know so I think it's difficult in that sense because you don't want to voice those thoughts to other people because you're scared of what they're going to say you know absolutely and whenever I'm working with anyone about intrusive thoughts and how powerful they can be but also how we can't control them I kind of get this out which is like a sand you know you're looking at the sand coming down and you can't control it you know you might have to watch it but if we were to try to take well have to watch it. But if we were to try to take, well, I can see through it. If we were to try to predict what's going to happen
你不想让那种事发生。所以我认为在那种意义上很困难，因为你不想向别人表达这些想法，因为你害怕他们会说什么。绝对。每当我与任何人讨论侵入性想法以及它们的力量，以及我们如何无法控制它们时，我就会拿出这个，就像沙子一样。你在看着沙子流下来，你无法控制它。你可能不得不看着它，但如果我们试图……好吧，我能看穿它。如果我们试图预测会发生什么，
or to make plans for what might happen if that bit falls or, you know, it really demonstrates quite nicely how intrusive, impulsive thoughts work. But that we need to just get better at watching the leaves in the stream and you know knowing that we will have these thoughts but if I was to throw you a tennis ball for example you don't have to catch it or you can catch it and put it down or you can throw it to somebody else you don't always need to take action with that and
或者为如果那部分掉下来会发生什么制定计划，或者……它确实很好地展示了侵入性、冲动性想法是如何运作的。但我们需要更好地学会观察溪流中的落叶，知道我们会产生这些想法。但如果我给你扔一个网球，你不必接住它，或者你可以接住它然后放下，或者你可以把它扔给别人。你不必总是对它采取行动，
keep it with you and like before you know it you've got 18 tennis balls up your jumper that you're trying to kind of juggle and balance you know we've we've got to learn that we've got choices of what to do with our impulsive trusive thoughts we just have to be able to build those stabilization skills and the distress tolerance skills to not judge ourselves, to know that we are capable of really wild thoughts, really wild ideas. And this is always where I sit for therapy. And whenever I'm working with anybody, I'm not going to say it on camera
把它留在身边。在你意识到之前，你的毛衣里已经有 18 个网球了，你正试图杂耍和平衡它们。我们必须学会，我们有选择权，可以决定如何处理我们的冲动性侵入想法。我们只需要能够建立那些稳定技能和痛苦耐受技能，不评判自己，知道我们有能力产生非常狂野的想法、非常狂野的念头。这就是我进行治疗时所处的位置。每当我与任何新客户合作时，我都会想出一个新的可能的可怕场景，我可以用我所能看到的东西在当地环境中造成破坏。所以我不会说出来，因为我不希望它突然被说成“特伦特博士说……”。但我们有能力产生这些东西。当我们审视同情聚焦疗法（Compassion Focused Therapy）时，我知道这对强迫症患者通常很关键，我们仍然是人类。人类曾经在角斗士战斗中观看所有那些暴力，并为之欢呼。所有那些在纳粹集中营里发生的事情，人类对其他人做了这些。我们有能力产生那些让我们产生想法的东西，但我们并不总是需要
because I don't want it to be used out of context. But every time I'm working with a new client, I come up with a new possible awful scenario that I could reap, you know, havoc on my local environment using what I can see. So I'm not going to say it because I don't want it to suddenly go, you know, Dr. Trent says that. But we are capable of generating things and the very, you know, when we're look at compassion focused therapy, which I know is often key for people with OCD, we are still humans and humans, you know, were in gladiatorial battles and going and watching all of that violence and, you know, cheering for it. And, you know, all of the stuff that's kind of happened in kind of Nazi concentration camps, you know, that's humans have done that to other humans. We're capable of coming up with stuff that generates us thoughts, but we don't always need to run
顺着那些想法和念头去做。这可能真的很糟糕。如果你没有根据这些想法采取行动，这并不能说明你什么。这真的很强大。你能告诉我们一些对你克服或控制强迫症有帮助的方法吗？好的，当然。在我进行任何强迫症治疗之前，我发现真正有帮助的第一件事是做了大量的正念冥想，我非常虔诚地做了。我每天都做。我坚持了几年，毫无例外，我每天至少冥想 10 分钟。对于强迫症，正念之所以如此有帮助，正如你刚才提到的，它是一种观察那些想法的方式。你知道，承认它们在那里，它们
with those thoughts and those ideas. And that can be really bad and it says you know so if you don't act upon the thoughts it says nothing about you you know and that's really powerful could you tell us about some of the approaches that have been instrumental for you overcoming or kind of containing the OCD yeah absolutely the first thing that I actually found really helped before I actually did any therapy for OCD was I did a lot of mindfulness meditation and I did that religiously. I, you know, I would do that every day. I did it for a couple of years, you know, without fail, I would meditate for at least 10 minutes every day. And with O OCD the reason that mindfulness is so helpful and it's as you've just mentioned it's kind of seeing those thoughts you know acknowledging them they're there they've they've
跳进了你的脑海，但一个想法仅仅是一个想法，不必赋予它任何意义。所以只是观察它，好的，然后让那个想法过去。因为最终它会……我们每天有成千上万个想法，所以那只是其中之一，如果我们只是看到它、承认它并让它过去，它最终会消失。显然，强迫症之所以变得如此痛苦，是因为我们赋予了这些想法太多的价值、太多的意义，我们试图摆脱它们。但一个非常常见的类比是：如果你说“不要想粉色大象”，你首先
popped into your head but a thought is just a thought and there doesn't have to be any kind of meaning attached to that thought so just observing it okay and letting that thought go because eventually it will you know we have I don't know how many thoughts thousands upon thousands of thoughts in just one day so that is just one of many and it will pass eventually if we just you know see it acknowledge it and let it go the obviously the reason that OCD becomes so distressing is because we attach a lot of value to those thoughts a lot of meaning to those thoughts and we try and get rid of them but you know a really common analogy is that one of you know if I were to say don't think of a pink elephant the first thing
想到的就是粉色大象。所以试图与这些想法战斗并把它们推开可能会适得其反。所以正念对我来说是一种非常有用的技术，只是让那些想法过去，而不是与它们争吵，只是看到它们并说“好的，它在这里，它会过去”。最终它们确实会过去。所以这非常有帮助。它与……我最终开始做一点暴露与反应预防疗法（ERP），这是 NHS 治疗强迫症的主要方法，本质上就是让你自己暴露在让你感到焦虑、让你感到痛苦的想法或事物中，而不执行你的强迫行为。所以你所做的行为……
you're going to think about is a pink elephant so you know trying to kind of battle those thoughts and push them away can be really counterproductive so mindfulness was a really useful technique for me and just kind of letting those thoughts and not you know having it out with them just seeing them and saying okay it's here and it will pass and eventually they do so it's it's really useful and it tied them really nicely to you know I did eventually start doing a bit of exposure and response prevention therapy which is you know the main kind of thing that they use in the NHS for treating OCD which is you know essentially kind of exposing yourself to you to the thought or the thing that makes you feel that anxiety, makes you feel that distress, and not carrying out your compulsion. So the behavior that you
你会想到一只粉色的大象，所以你知道，试图去对抗这些想法并把它们推开实际上可能会适得其反。因此，正念对我来说是一种非常有用的技巧，就是顺其自然，不去和它们争辩，只是看着它们，对自己说‘好吧，它来了，它会过去的’，最终它们确实会过去。所以这真的很有用，而且它与我后来开始进行的一些暴露与反应预防疗法结合得非常好，这你知道是英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）治疗强迫症的主要方法，本质上就是让你暴露在那个让你感到焦虑、让你感到痛苦的想法或事物中，而不去执行你的强迫行为。也就是你所做的行为
would do to bring that anxiety down. So mindfulness, I found, worked really well, kind of hand in hand with the ERP therapy to kind of make me become a bit more tolerant of that anxiety and make me feel a bit more comfortable in just knowing that it will pass and I don't have to act on anything I don't have to do anything to make that anxiety go away it just will so that was a huge thing and that's been you know absolutely fundamental in in treating my OCD. Good I'm pleased that you found something that's really helped to take control actually to take control back and I know sometimes people are so distressed that actually medication helps take the edge off to be able to tolerate any distress at all or any more distress about not doing the the activity because there's always so much distress anyway.
能减轻焦虑。我发现正念非常有效，它与ERP（暴露与反应预防）疗法相辅相成，让我对焦虑的耐受力有所提高，也让我感到更自在，因为我知道焦虑终会过去，我不必采取任何行动，也不必做任何事来消除它，它自然会消失。这对我来说意义重大，也是我治疗强迫症（OCD）的根本所在。很好，我很高兴你找到了真正能帮助你重新掌控生活的方法。我知道有时人们会感到非常痛苦，以至于药物能起到缓解作用，让人能够忍受哪怕一点点的痛苦，或者不再因为无法完成某项活动而感到额外的痛苦，因为无论如何，痛苦总是存在的。
But the idea of upsetting the apple cart is too much. So sometimes medication can help people to take the edge off to then be able to tolerate the therapy. But for anybody watching this, I want them to know this is not going to be flooding. This is not going to be us cutting you off. Cold turkey. You're not doing that anymore.
但打破常规的想法让人难以承受。所以有时药物可以帮助人们缓解压力，从而能够坚持接受治疗。但对于任何观看此视频的人，我想让他们知道，这绝不是“洪水猛兽”式的强行暴露。我们不会突然切断你的所有退路。我们不会那样做。
You just got to tolerate it. It isn't that. That would be so inhumane. You know, we need to build up so that the distress is tolerated and then build upon those blocks. But also know that with any setbacks, sometimes we need to work a little bit backwards before we can then work forwards again. This is compassionate, this is humane, this is working with you, not against you. And, you know, that is really important that really somebody's buying into not wanting to suffer this way anymore and to find a way back to more balance, more well-being, less problems,
你只需要去忍受它。事实并非如此。那样做太不人道了。我们需要循序渐进，让痛苦变得可以忍受，然后在此基础上不断进步。但也要明白，在遇到挫折时，有时我们需要先退后一步，才能再次前进。这是充满同情心和人道主义的做法，是与你并肩作战，而不是与你作对。而且，一个人真正下定决心不再这样受苦，并找到回归平衡、健康和减少问题的道路，这真的非常重要。
less risks. Because people deserve to have richly rewarding lives where they have careers, where they have intimate relationships if they want them, where they have friendships, where they can tolerate being around their own children or other people's you know and just that life feels like it's worth living and it feels there's a point in it you know yeah absolutely and a really you know something that i always say to clients that i work with now who who come in with with OCD or with you know intrusive thoughts compulsions is that the therapy for OCD is difficult you know you do have to put a lot of work into that and you know it can be really distressing at times what was harder for me than you know doing the exposure and response prevention therapy was actually living day-to-day
减少风险。因为人们理应拥有丰富而有意义的生活，拥有事业，拥有他们想要的亲密关系，拥有友谊，能够忍受与自己的孩子或他人相处，并且觉得生活值得过，觉得生活有意义。是的，绝对是这样。我总是对现在合作的强迫症或有侵入性思维、强迫行为的客户说，强迫症的治疗很困难，你确实需要付出很多努力，有时过程会非常痛苦。对我来说，比进行暴露与反应预防疗法更难的是日常生活中
with with OCD so that was a choice that I had to make was am I you know gonna commit to this and do it and have the support of someone there who's you know helping and guiding me through it or you know do I kind of live with this and with it becoming worse and worse you know with every passing day because as you mentioned earlier on it comes to a point where we kind of habituate to those compulsions almost and we have to do more and more to make ourselves feel better so the OCD only gets worse do I continue with that or do I you know commit to this therapy and you know this moment of the stress knowing that actually this is this is going to be really useful for me yeah absolutely and reaching out
与强迫症共处。所以我必须做出选择：我是要致力于此，在有人帮助和指导的情况下完成治疗，还是就这样生活下去，看着它一天天变得越来越糟？正如你之前提到的，我们最终会习惯那些强迫行为，为了让自己感觉好一点，我们不得不做更多的事情，所以强迫症只会越来越严重。我是要继续那样，还是致力于这种治疗，忍受这一刻的压力，因为我知道这对我来说真的很有用？是的，绝对是这样，寻求帮助
to ask for help can feel like a really brave step but it's really really important and people do get better from OCD you know it might be that you use those strategies every day but people get better from OCD you know it might be that you use those strategies every day but people get better and do have that meaningful enjoyable life thank you so much for sharing your your wise insights with our audience is there anything I haven't asked you that you think is important that that we do cover that we think about yeah I think a huge thing that is really important and something that I didn't know sort of a few years back was that OCD is treated you know really widely throughout the NHS you know I remember going through a phase where you know I thought that this was really uncommon
可能感觉是一个非常勇敢的举动，但这真的非常非常重要，人们确实可以从强迫症中康复。可能你每天都在使用这些策略，但人们确实会好起来，过上那种有意义、令人愉悦的生活。非常感谢你与我们的听众分享你睿智的见解。还有什么我没问到，但你认为很重要、我们应该讨论的内容吗？是的，我认为有一点非常重要，也是我几年前不知道的，那就是强迫症在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）中得到了非常广泛的治疗。我记得我曾经历过一个阶段，当时我认为这是一种非常罕见的
disorder and it was going to be really difficult to get help but actually you know the the talking therapy services you know throughout the NHS across the UK they all will bring you in and treat you for for OCD and the practitioners there they do have an understanding of OCD so I know it's really incredibly scary and incredibly difficult to to reach out for that support and you don't you don't always want to tell someone what's going on in your own head but just please be aware that you know there are trained professionals out there who who know what you're going through who who will understand, who will listen to you and will, will give you the help that you need. Yeah, absolutely. And yes, don't feel like you're struggling alone because, you know, people are just trying to make the best of worlds with these wild, tricky brains that we've got, you know, we're just humans and, you know, that's just how it is.
疾病，而且很难获得帮助。但实际上，英国各地的NHS谈话疗法服务都会接收并治疗强迫症患者，那里的从业者对强迫症有深入的了解。我知道寻求这种支持确实非常可怕且困难，你并不总是想告诉别人你脑子里在想什么，但请务必意识到，有训练有素的专业人员了解你的处境，他们会理解你、倾听你，并为你提供所需的帮助。是的，绝对是这样。而且，不要觉得你在独自挣扎，因为人们只是在用我们拥有的这些狂野、棘手的大脑努力过好生活，我们只是人类，事实就是如此。
Thank you so much. Wishing you well with your work as a PWP and beyond whatever that looks like for you. And keep up with that mindfulness. Keep doing that. I will. I will. Thanks, Marianne. Thank you. You too. Thank you so much to our guest faye i did forget to mention um where you can
非常感谢。祝你在PWP（心理健康从业者）的工作以及未来的任何职业道路上一切顺利。请继续保持正念。继续这样做。我会的。我会的。谢谢你，玛丽安。谢谢。你也一样。非常感谢我们的嘉宾费伊。我忘了提一下，如果你想
catch up with faye if you want to connect with her she is on linkedin and she is faye with an e so f a y e wilson more about her and what she does. Mainly follow her journey in her career too. Please, if you are struggling with OCD or you care about somebody who is, please do book yourself a GP appointment or, you know, encourage someone that you love to do that. Maybe offer to go with them if that would be useful. You can also come and connect with me on my social media channels where I am Dr. Marianne Trent. Absolutely everywhere. And I've got a sprinkling of different content that goes in different places as well. So do come and follow me everywhere. And of course, we've got the free Aspiring Psychologist Community Facebook group where you can come and watch the exclusive videos called Marianne's Motivation and Mindset, which happen weekly on Fridays. If it's your time and you're in the psychology profession, you're ready for the next step, please do also check out the Aspiring Psychologist membership. And if you found this video helpful, I know that you'll really find the one I did with Alexandra on OCD and complex trauma to
联系费伊，可以在领英（LinkedIn）上找到她，她的名字是Faye，拼写是F-A-Y-E Wilson。你可以了解更多关于她和她的工作，主要是关注她的职业旅程。如果你正在与强迫症作斗争，或者你关心的人正在经历这些，请务必预约全科医生（GP），或者鼓励你爱的人去预约。如果有用的话，可以主动提出陪他们一起去。你也可以在我的社交媒体频道上与我联系，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）。我在所有平台上都有账号，并且会发布各种不同的内容。所以请务必在各处关注我。当然，我们还有免费的“有抱负的心理学家社区”Facebook群组，你可以在那里观看每周五更新的独家视频《玛丽安的动力与心态》。如果你正处于心理学职业生涯的阶段，准备好迈出下一步，也请务必查看“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”。如果你觉得这个视频有帮助，我知道你也会觉得我与亚历山德拉关于强迫症和复杂创伤的对话
be really useful as well. I will link that in the show notes and it will be on screen at the end of this for you to just click through and watch as well. Please also consider the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book, the Clinical Psychologist Collective book, and the brand new kid on the block, An Autistic Anthology, which is real life stories of people with autism diagnosis, talking about their experiences working in mental health. Thank you so much for being part of my world. Do be kind to yourself. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner.
也非常有用。我会把链接放在节目说明中，视频结束时屏幕上也会出现链接，你可以直接点击观看。也请考虑阅读《有抱负的心理学家合集》、《临床心理学家合集》，以及最新推出的《自闭症选集》，里面讲述了自闭症诊断患者在心理健康领域工作的真实生活故事。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。请善待自己。如果你想成为一名心理学家，让这成为你的指南。有这个播客陪伴，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是玛丽安·特伦特博士的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我的名字是贾娜，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。
I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我读了《临床心理学家合集》。我发现书中关于各种不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。成为临床心理学家的途径之多让我感到惊讶，而且没有完美的途径。这让我充满了信心，意识到我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。